welcome to this first video and actually
the first video in the playlist on
differential equations I know I touched
on this before when we did harmonic
motion and I think I might have touched
on it in other subjects but now ba-bye
because of your request we'll do a whole
playlist on this and that's I think a
fairly useful thing because differential
equations is something that shows up in
a whole in a whole set of a different
field I've been requested by someone
who's starting an economics ph.d program
to do this I've been requested by some
people who are going into physics some
people who are going into engineering so
it's widely applicable area of study so
let's just get started before I keep
going off on useless stuff so the
differential equation so the first
question is what is a differential
equation you know what an equation is
what is a differential equation well a
differential equation is an equation
that involves an unknown function and
it's derivative so what do I mean by
that well let's say that I said that Y
prime Y prime plus y is equal to X plus
3 here the unknown function is y we
could have written it as Y of X or we
could have written we could have written
this as dy DX the derivative of Y with
respect to X plus this unknown function
y is equal to X plus 3 we also could
have written F prime of X plus f of X is
equal to X plus 3 all of these would
have been valid ways of writing this
exact same differential equation and
what's interesting here and how this is
a departure from what we've learned
before about just regular equations is
let me write down a regular equation
just to remind you what they look like
so a regular equation if we had one
variable would look something like this
I don't know x squared plus I don't know
the cosine of X is equal to the square
root of x I just made that up here the
solution is a number or sometimes it's a
set of numbers sometimes there's more
than one right
if you have a polynomial you could have
more than one values of X that satisfy
this equation here for a differential
equation the solution is a function our
goal is to figure out what function of X
and here I wrote f of X explicitly but
what function of X explicitly satisfies
this relationship or this equation so
let me show you what I mean by that and
I have my differential equations book
from college so I'm going to use that as
as we go so let's say that I'm just
writing down let's see they have this as
a differential equation Y and I'm not
going to show you necessarily how to
necessarily solve them just yet because
we have to learn some tricks first but I
think a good place to start is just so
you understand what a differential
equation is and so you don't get
confused with the traditional equation
so they have this differential instance
this Y prime prime so the second
derivative of Y with respect to X plus 2
times the first derivative of Y with
respect to X minus 3y is equal to zero
and they gave us the solutions here and
what they want us to do is show that
these are solutions and I think this is
a good place to just at least understand
what a differential equation is and what
its solution means so they say y 1 of X
is equal to e to the minus 3x so they
claim that this is a solution of this
differential equation so let me show to
you that this is well what is if this is
y 1 what's Y well I don't have to well
let me just write Y 1 what's Y 1 prime
what's the derivative of this well just
do the chain rule the derivative of the
whole function with respect to this part
of it what we get is just 2 e to the
minus 3x and then you take the
derivative of the inside so that's just
the derivative of the outside eetu the
minus 3x and the derivative of the
inside is minus 3
right and then the second derivative of
y1 is equal to we just take the
derivative of this and that's just equal
to plus nine right minus 3 times minus 3
e to the minus 3x now let's let's verify
that if we substitute y1 and its
derivatives back into this differential
equation set it that that it holds true
so Y prime prime that's this so we get 9
e to the minus 3x plus 2 y prime plus 2
times y prime well this is y prime so 2
times minus 3 e to the minus 3x plus oh
sorry minus 3 times y well why is this
so minus 3 times e to the minus 3x well
what does that equal that we get 9 e to
the minus 3x minus 6 e to the minus 3x
minus 3 e to the minus 3x well what does
that equal we have 9 of something minus
6 of something minus 3 or something so
that just equals 0
doesn't matter of 0 whatever so that
equals 0 so we verified that for this
function for y1 is equal to e to the
minus 3x it satisfies this to this
differential equation now there's
something interesting here and you've
kind of touched on this with regular
equations is that this might not be the
only solution in fact we'll learn in
maybe a video or two that often the
solution isn't just a function it could
be a class of functions where usually
they're all kind of the same function
but you have you know a different of
constants but I'll show you that in a
second but here they actually show us
that there's another solution that is
this this will actually work with we
could try the equation y 2 of X is equal
to well just some two simple e to the X
we could verify that right what's the
first and second derivatives with B to
the X well they're just e to the X so
the second derivative of Y 2 is just e
to the X
plus two x plus two times the first
derivative is what well the first
derivative of e to the X still e to the
x/2 e to the X minus three times the
function minus 3e to the X well one plus
two minus three well that equals zero
again so this was also a solution to
this differential equation now before we
go on in the next one I'll show you some
fairly straightforward differential
equations to to solve that's why I think
it's a good time now now that you
hopefully have a grasp of what a
differential equation is and what its
solution is that a solution isn't a
number it's solution is a function or
set of functions or a class of functions
it's a good time to just go over a
little bit of terminology so there's two
big classifications well actually
there's there's a first big one ordinary
and partial differential equations I
think you might already guess what that
means an ordinary differential equation
is what I wrote down it's one variable
with respect to another variable or one
function with respect to say X and its
derivatives partial differential
equations we'll get into later that's
more complicated that's what a function
can be a function of more than one
variable and it has you know you could
have the derivative with respect to x
and y and z we won't worry about that
right now if your functions and their
derivatives are a function of only one
variable then we're dealing with an
ordinary differential equation and
that's what this playlist' will deal
with ordinary differential equations now
within ordinary differential equations
there's two ways of classifying and they
kind of overlap you have your order so
what is the order of my differential
equation and then you have this notion
of whether it is linear or nonlinear and
I think the best way to figure this out
is just to to write down examples so
this differential amiright down one I'm
getting this from my college equations
book x squared times the second
derivative of Y with respect to X
plus x times the first derivative of Y
with respect to X plus 2y is equal to
sine of X so the first question is here
is what is the order well the order all
the order is is the highest derivative
that exists in your in your equation the
highest derivative of the function under
question right the solution of this is
going to be a Y that satisfies a Y of X
that satisfies this equation and the
order is the highest derivative of that
function well the highest derivative
here is the second derivative so this
has order to order 2 or you can call
this a second order ordinary
differential equations now the second
thing we have to figure out is this
linear or is this a nonlinear
differential equation so a differential
equation is linear if all of the
functions and its derivatives are are
essentially well for lack of a better
word linear what do I mean by that I
mean it you don't have a Y squared or
you don't have a dy over DX squared or
you don't have Y times the second
derivative of Y so this is this example
I just wrote here this is a second-order
linear equation because you have the
firt the second derivative the first
derivative and Y but they're not
multiplied by the function or the
derivatives now if this equation were if
I rewrote it as x squared d the second
derivative of Y with respect to x
squared is equal to sine of X and let's
say I were to square this now all of a
sudden I have a nonlinear differential
equation this is nonlinear this is
linear because I squared I multiplied
the second derivative of Y with respect
I multiply two times itself another
example of a nonlinear equation is if I
wrote Y times D squid the second
derivative of Y with respect to X is
equal to sine of X
this is also nonlinear because I
multiplied the function times its second
derivative notice here I did multiply
stuff times the second derivative but I
was the independent variable X that I
multiplied but anyway I've run out of
time and hopefully that gives you a good
at least survey of what a differential
equation is in the next video we'll
start actually solving them see you soon